So now that we have multiple solutions,
I guess it's time to come up to
a decision, and
to come up with one solution, right?
>> That's right.
So, the decide stage is important
in helping filter down
the ideas that were collected.
The previous stage,
which is about diverging,
has made it so that everyone has created
a lot of sketches, and they're starting
to develop some passion and
attachment to the things that they have.
During the deside stage, we ask the team
to put their ideas on the board so
everyone can see them.
At that point,
we ask people to remain silent.
We call this process Zen Voting.
Just like in a zen spirit,
you want to be quiet and
consider things in a reflective manner.
During this process, we ask people
to review what the sketches
are before anyone gets to bias
them with their opinions.
So, as they review the sketches
that other people have created,
they start thinking, what do they
like about the other solution?
And you're always curious.
I made this.
What did the others make?
It's fun to see that.
After everybody has voted, it is time
to actually discuss things in person.
So, something that's not natural to
teams happened that's really valuable.
People had individual,
personal time to be creative.
Then they have personal time to view
results, and they have time to consider
and cast their vote before anyone else
could say, I think this is important.
And so they are biased.
So now that they have gone through that,
they're ready to look at
things as a community.
As a community,
the team reviews what are the ideas,
what are the most popular ones and
then quickly they get to see
more clearly some things rise to the top
and maybe others are less important.
So there minds are changed based
on what the community has decided.
Research shows that this
community-based voting
can be more powerful than
the decisions of a single expert.
For example,
if you have a horse race and
exports betting on the horses, and
if you have a crowdsourcing solution,
and you're testing how a crowd
making predictions on who will win.
It is likely that the crowd
might often be the experts
over what you usually think, is that
the expert will be more powerful.
Crowdsourcing a decision makes
the team decide faster and
it helps the team often gather
the wisdom of everyone who is involved.
>> So what could go wrong in this stage?
>> What could go wrong in this stage?
Decisions are a crucial
aspect of what teams do.
In fact, the life of a team is made of
all of the decisions that they make.
So we cannot pretend this is
an easy process for teams.
Things can go wrong if one person
is trying to overpower and
put opinions over others.
This happens all the time.
This is why we have
a leader of a sprint.
The leader of the sprint is
watching the entire group.
They want to make sure that the
introverts and the extroverts are heard,
the designers and the engineers,
the CEO and the intern.
Everyone could have a great
decision at this point.
>> So at this stage we look at the
solutions, we vote, and we make a call.
>> That's right.